пані Юлія Тимошенко Дякуємо за інтерв'ю
ДВ нещодавно відбулися найбільші кадрові
зміни в українському уряді спочатку
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії що ви
думаєте про відставку Олексія резнікова
з посади міністра оборони перш за все
сьогодні
воюючій Україні міністр оборони - це є
над звичайна важливий керівник і для
України дуже важливо щоб все був
керівник вищого рівня кваліфікації
міністр оборони за Конституцією України
- це креатура президента України тільки
президент має право як головна
командувач країни обирати міністра
оборони і подавати в парламент його
кандидатуру і в цьому випадку ми
підтримуємо президента що він звільняє
пана резнікова і бути призначати вносити
іншу кандидатуру і в цьому випадку ми як
українська команда залишаємося абсолютно
спільними єдиними Ви програли
Президентські вибори 2019 року
Володимиру зеленському Як ви оцінюєте те
як він керує державою під час війни
війна - це особливий виклик для нашої
країни
до війни ми були в достатньо радикальній
опозиції до президента Зеленського ми не
поділяли його внутрішнє реформи його дії
І власне кажучи до війни у нього і
підтримка в суспільстві достатньо
стрімко падала але Війна змінила все ми
можемо розділяти або не розділяти дії
президента в внутрішній політиці Але ми
не можемо сьогодні бути не єдиними не
спільними для того щоб захистити Україну
І тому з перших днів війни ми зібралися
разом з президентом України З усією
політичною командою України і ми сказали
що зараз не буде владою опозиції зараз
буде єдина українська команда яка мусить
перемогти і разом з усім вільним світом
ви
ми і сьогодні можливо не все підтримуємо
що робить команда президента внутрішній
політиці України а ми не все підтримуємо
те що робиться сьогодні в економічному
фінансовому секторі але ми твердо знаємо
що у України після перемоги буде шанс
побудувати все правильно і цей шанс не
буде втрачений ми не програємо після
перемоги мир але сьогодні на першому
місці стоїть перемога А це означає
єдність України в усіх її сферах в тому
числі в політичні
однією з ваших обіцянок на виборах 2019
року було повернення Криму нині серед
союзників Києва лунають припущення про
те що Україна могла б поступитися Росії
певними територіями для того щоб
закінчити війну Як ви до цього ставитеся
по-перше вкрай негативна це зразу я хочу
сказати і Україна яка заплатила таку
тяжку ціну за те щоб перемогти в цій
лінії щоб зберегти свою державу свою
територіальну цілісність вона не
відмовиться від жодного сантиметра своєї
території і не тільки тому що це наша
рідна земля А ще і тому що якщо тільки
від України почнуть відрізати шматки
нашої території це буде означати що той
порядок які встановлений на базі
Організації Об'єднаних Націй після
Другої світової війни більше не працює і
тоді кожну країну яка комусь здасться
слабкою можна буде нарізати на шматки як
салямі не можна цього допустити і тому
Україна буде боротися за цілісність
своєї території і це означає боротися за
збереження того світового порядку які
стверджений після Другої світової війни
це недоторканність кордонів якщо тільки
вільний світ дозволить хоч якусь країну
різати на шматки і уступати агресору які
забирають цю територію сили зброї це
буде означати що в світі відкриється
ящик Пандори тобто перед його кордонів
стане новою реальністю світу чи хочемо
ми всі того Думаю ні your friends ви
зараз називаєте президента Росії
Володимира Путіна агресором з ним вам
доводилося вести перемовини в Росії коли
ви вдруге обіймали посаду
прем'єр-міністрки України наскільки
сильно ви б опанували Володимиру Путіну
тоді знаючи що станеться можливо нині
замислюєтеся що варто було бути більш
обережною
Ну так ми були непоступливі те що
стосується інтересів таких глибоких
національних інтересів України або
Європи і це було видно коли була газова
криза
2009 року коли насправді Путін не
пояснюючи нічого в самий розпал морозів
вимкнув природній газ для всієї Європи
яка тоді отримувала російський газ через
Україну І це був надзвичайно агресивний
і жорстокий крок і тоді Україна була на
гострі Але це був перший сигнал на який
треба було звертати увагу всім
європейським лідерам і європейським
народам і тоді треба було зрозуміти що
такими методами переходячи червоні лінії
працює Путін і тоді треба було діяти і
не допускати розвитку подій аж до сього
Але і в 2007 році на мюнхенській
конференції коли виступив Путін своєю
програмою промовою вже було зрозуміло що
агресивність несприйняття реальності
по суті поступ проти світового порядку
це його стратегія зовнішньої політики і
в 2007 році я написала статтю якраз про
те що треба зупинити Путін це був 2007
рік але мене не почули і сьогодні Ми всі
маємо наслідки нам треба бачити
агресивних лідерів задовго до того як
вони починають руйнувати світ і діяти
превентивно а не гасити потім пожежу Ну
і безумовно дух 2008 рік коли я як
прем'єр-міністр подала заявку щодо
вступу України в НАТО що гарно дій щодо
членства в НАТО і якщо б тоді
дослухалися до моєї пропозиції і Україні
дали план дій щодо членства в НАТО
Україні відкрили двері НАТО в 2008 році
сьогодні не було би ніякої війни
сьогодні була би в спокої Європа були
без сотні тисяч людей живі і сьогодні не
було би тих наслідків трагедії яку
сьогодні відчуває і Вся Європа і весь
світ від війни яка відбувається в
Україні треба діяти вчасно Ось мій
висновок Ну і безумовно мій уряд також
подавав ну практично провів всю роботу
яка стосується
підписання угоди про асоціацію між
Україною Європейським Союзом за всю мою
політику на посаді прем'єр-міністра зі
мною розрахувалися коли прийшов на
посаду президента Яну
на базі величезної фальсифікації виборів
і тоді мене Кинули у різницю якраз за
таку політику не Янукович мене кинув за
ґрати А це був крем з Януковичем тому що
Янукович це маріонетка Кремля і тому
вони не прощають таких речей Вони завжди
діяли жорстоко і сьогоднішня війна - це
просто ще одна жорстокість кровопролиття
насилля для того щоби ствердити свою
імперську політику
ви згадали про своє ув'язнення вас
визнали винною у перевищення службових
повноважень у справі газового договору з
Росією ви відома людина в Україні і вас
називають газовою принцесою кажуть через
те як ви збагатилися завдяки газовим
угодам у світі де Довіра це все де
Україна має показати союзникам що хоче
викорінити і викорінює корупцію чи не є
вискомпромонтова свою особою З усією
повагою до вас
перш за все
загальновідомо що автором всіх цих
репресій проти мене був Кремль і Це
очевидно і плюс манафорт який теж це
було встановлено разом з Януковичем всю
цю компанію організували але є рішення
американського суду українського суду і
Європейського Суду з прав людини що все
що проти мене робилося не мали ніяких
правових підстав є безліч рішення заяв
конгресу сенату Європейського парламенту
парламентської асамблеї Ради Європи в
той час коли я була засуджена на мій
захист і коли мене Кинули у в'язницю то
дуже багато лідерів парламентів країн
виступили публічно на мій захист
розуміючи що це політичне переслідування
і можу сказати що стояти проти
авторитарної корумпованої системи яка
керується крем на жаль дуже небезпечно і
я на собі Це дуже і дуже сильно відчула
І абсолютно точно що Путін вибрав момент
піти проти України після того як
Янукович зайняв посаду президента і
Практично на всі силові посади поставив
російський громадян які знищували нашу
армію знекровлювали можливість України
захищатися і все це було якраз
передумовою а вірніше
заохоченням Кремля піти проти України Я
боролась з цим я була опонентом
Януковича я була його смертельним Богом
і тому на жаль проти мене працювала вся
ця машина але сьогодні Україна абсолютно
інша сьогодні Україна позбавилася майже
цією п'ятої колони Кремля і тому наша
єдність українська всередині країни і
наша єдність усім вільним світом
сьогодні вдає можливість Україні а
остаточно скинути ярмо російської
колонізації і стати насправді незалежною
країною частиною західного вільного
світу
чимало українців не вірять у те що ви
жертва повторюся вважається що ви добре
заробили на сумнівних газових Водах
Це абсолютно не відповідає дійсності
повністю з'ясовані всі обставини і є всі
рішення судів які доводять зворотнє
Просто я опинилась на гострій політичної
боротьби і тому та Пропаганда яка проти
мене була зроблена опонентами вона
достатньо сильно була підтримана
мільйонними фінансовими ресурсами і тому
для мене ключовим є рішення судів які
чітко і ясно скасували всі ці
абсолютно необґрунтовані речі а просто
коли ти йдеш в політику і коли ти стаєш
проти системи А ще і проти системи яка
підтримана кремлем тобі треба бути
готовим до будь-чого і сьогодні ви
бачите що і в Росії і в Білорусі
опоненти режима сидять по тюрмам те саме
було
але країни сьогодні одужує і я вірю що в
Україні політичні репресії політично
мотивовані переслідування вже більше
ніколи не будуть мати місця І до речі я
хочу просто нагадати що та кримінальна
справа яка була ініційованою Януковичем
вона якраз проти тієї газової угоди яка
була підтримана Європейським Союзом була
підтримана паном бароза вона якраз
вводила формульний підхід до формування
ціни і виводила Україну з-підзалежності
від Кремля Це була абсолютно
ринкова сильна угода за яку Власне
кажучи мені і помстилися вона була дуже
невигідна не Російській Федерації не 5
колонії Кремля яка очолювала тоді
Україну І тому це
кримінальна справа яка
всім Відома і вона не має там ніяких
елементів корупції і звинувачення в
корупції не було Це було звинувачення ви
правильно сказали в перебільшенні
посадових моїх повноважень але суди
довели що там не було навіть натяку на
будь-якій злочин це просто була
політична справа
Ukraine в Україні мали б відбутися
вибори наступного 2024 року чи вважаєте
ви що вибори мають відбутися якщо війна
триватиме і чи балотуватиметься ви у
президенти ви вже робили це тричі Чи
хочете ви ще бути Президентом України
ну перш за все позиція нашої команди та
й не тільки нашою це всіх людей які
мають здравий розсудок що під час такої
гарячої війни вибори в Україні неможливі
тому що
це по суті не будуть вибори значна
кількість людей які сьогодні або
вимушені були виїхати з України або
воюють за Україну вони будуть позбавлені
права або балотуватися або голосувати не
може сьогодні в країні яку
атакують ракетами кожного дня проводити
з будь-які політичні процеси це
недопустимо і неможливо тому ми за те
щоби були демократичні чесні абсолютно
вільні вибори але хоча б через півроку
після завершення цієї війни тоді це
будуть реальні справжні вибори а
сьогодні чесні відкриті
конкурентні вибори з участю всіх
громадян України провести неможливо і
точно можу сказати що наша команда
обов'язково буде Приймати участь в
парламентських місцевих виборах тому
Наша команда сильна і вона має дуже
виварений курс чіткий курс як виводити
Україну в післявоєнний період з цієї
економічної фінансової соціальної руїни
і тому однозначно так що стосується
президентських виборів Мені здається що
Час покаже це все буде залежати від того
коли завершиться війна як вона
завершиться А я переконана перемогою і
тоді команда буде приймати рішення
відносно президентських виборів і участі
нашої команди в них
пані Тимошенко екс-прем'єр-міністрка
України Дякую за ваш час